bueno
voy a empezar con esto
todos vamos a morir varias veces en esta
vida
si vamos a quiero hablarles de morir y
de renacer
yo soy un como comentaba un especialista
en trauma soy terapeuta especialista en
trauma y me dedico a ayudar a la gente
en situación de caos
hace más de 10 años empecé a combinar
neurociencia budismo psicología yoga
para ayudar desde la visión de oriente y
occidente a la gente a superar lo que se
llama en estas situaciones límite
puede ser no sé
un divorcio empezar de nuevo en un país
nuevo
un nuevo trabajo una enfermedad crónica
todos tienen una cierta relación con el
caos
vamos a explicarlo desde otra manera
quien ha construido castillos de arena
en la playa levanten la mano
todos sabemos que para construir un buen
castillo de arena hay que ir a cierto
límite entre el agua y la arena seca es
una delgada línea que ahí está en el
medio si nosotros nos vamos demasiado
hacia afuera la arena está muy seca y el
castillo se deshace está demasiado
adentro el castillo también se deshace
por el exceso de agua
el orden y la armonía existen en una
delgada línea que está ahí en el medio
nosotros creemos que podemos evitar el
caos quien quiere evitar el caos en su
vida
y quien lo consiguió
jaja
evitar el caos parece de tarea inútil
porque por otro lado el caos no es una
mala noticia
trump a ripoll que era un
maestro de meditación de tíbet decía que
el caos siempre debe ser recibido como
una buena noticia
cuál es la noticia es una cuestión de
perspectiva
nosotros podemos imagínense una ola muy
grande viniendo hacia nosotros podemos
imaginarnos fácilmente debajo de ella y
arrastrados por la corriente o bien
podríamos montar encima de la ola y
estar por encima del tsunami y llegando
mucho más lejos
el caos tiene la posibilidad de
propulsar nos hacia adelante es eso lo
que yo vengo trabajando y enseñándole a
la gente que se encuentra en situaciones
límite
nuestra mente tiene la posibilidad de
ayudarnos a hacer eso
nosotros podemos elegir cuando nos
enfermamos en realidad no dependemos
mucho también de cómo nos sintamos
nosotros si nos sentimos débiles o
tristes en general nuestra defensa es
más débil y si nos sentimos fuertes más
felices nos recuperamos antes
a través de ese trabajo que yo vengo
enseñando me tocó enfrentarme a mí en
primera persona con el caos hace muy
poco
mi abuela tenía un dicho que a mí me
encanta repetir que es si quieres hacer
reír a dios conoce cómo termina cuéntale
tus planes
después de haberme mudado a noruega y
haber empezado una vida nueva allí
ayudando a la gente que se instala en el
país
yo dio una vida muy sana hago yoga
medito me cuido
lo que pasó a continuación la verdad es
que no me lo esperaba
hace un año atrás en septiembre del año
pasado decidí ir al médico porque
después de muchos dolores de cabeza y de
espalda que no se iban me costaba mucho
dormir y tenía muchas dificultades
inclusive roncaba mucho así que yendo al
médico el médico me pidió que me hiciera
una resonancia magnética me llamó dos
horas después para decirme
no hay una buena forma de decir esto
tengo los resultados de tus imágenes y
tienes un tumor cerebral
no me acuerdo mucho de lo que pasó ese
día
la verdad es que un 30 por ciento de las
personas a lo largo de su vida tienen
que enfrentar un diagnóstico piénsenlo
un minuto y miren alrededor de esta sala
estamos hablando de una de cada tres
personas
nunca pensé que iba a ser yo y nunca
pensé que gracias a lo que venía
haciendo y llevando una vida sana y
ayudando al resto de las personas
tuviera que ser yo
aquí hay dos en la sala que se salvan
porque ya me tocó a mí hay dos
que pueden respirar profundo que me va a
tocar a mí tener que enfrentarme con
esto
esto es lo que aprendí
del caos
no recuerdo mucho de ese día no sé si
les habrá pasado alguna vez recibiendo
una mala noticia y la mente ya no graba
y uno lo que puede sentir es el corazón
en la garganta
constantemente la sensación de estar
temblando
después hubo varios días difíciles donde
tenía que ir al médico a que más
revisara
y lo primero que quise hacer fue poder
ver el tumor cara a cara
y ahí estaba
en la parte de atrás de mi cabeza
grande como una pelota de golf
a la salida del hospital llamó un amigo
y me dice
como estas como es y le digo es grande
se va es grande y me dice y cómo te
sentís yo me siento bien pero no
entiendo lo que pasa y me dice tenés
foto porque de estos amigos que en él sí
que le gusta ver en detalle por eso lo
comparto con ustedes
y le digo si ahora te la paso y cuando
la ve me dice parece que tuviera como
dos bracitos como que estuviera
saludando
le dio si parece
y me dice usted se acordará algo digo yo
me parece que lo había alguna vez esto
me dice cómo es esa película de disney
cuál es ese personaje de disney y el
verde que mike wazowski
y así fue como le puse nombre a mi tumor
y me ayudó a perderle el miedo porque
hay una cosa que hay que tener en cuenta
que aunque
podría haberme matado podría verme
dificultado mi calidad de vida
por el resto de mi vida
es parte mía y yo lo creía dentro mío es
tan mío como mi pelo como mi mano
abrazar el caos también significa poder
abrazar el síntoma
abrazar el diagnóstico la dificultad y
utilizarlo como la ola que nos impulsa
hacia adelante
la verdad es que por la ubicación que
tenía a mike
era complicado y como yo trabajo en esto
para mí fue bastante fácil saber qué
por el hermoso lugar que había elegido
para anidar las personas que pasan por
intervenciones de este tipo tienen
muchas dificultades a veces problemas
para el habla para caminar para mover
sus brazos la vista
eso no hizo fácil la espera
un día el médico después de varios
chequeos me dice la operación va a ser
mañana
y empezó a explicarme cómo se iba a
meter en la zona mejor custodiada del
cuerpo humano para usando bisturí sierra
circular material de relleno grapas de
titanio me iba a sacar este o visitó que
yo tenía en la cabeza
mientras él me lo explicaba con mucho
orgullo y realmente maravillado por los
avances de la ciencia yo no podía dejar
de temblar y me lo tuvo que repetir tres
o cuatro veces para poder entender de lo
que me estaba hablando
le pedí quedarme a solas en su oficina e
hice en ese momento lo que le digo a
todo el mundo que tiene que hacer y
empecé a saltar a sacudirme todo el
tiempo hasta que al fin pude darme el
miedo del cuerpo
en ese momento tuve un pensamiento que
hoy me causa gracia me escapo no vuelvo
mañana
y de repente me di vuelta y vi en su
en la pantalla de su escritorio a la
imagen de
quien quiere vivir con una bomba de
tiempo en la cabeza
la verdad es que sólo le tengo miedo al
dolor
tuve cálculos renales quien haya tenido
cálculos renales sabe de lo que estoy
hablando si le tenía miedo a la muerte a
no poder hacer todo aquello que quería
hacer
lo que tenía pensado para el resto de mi
vida como decía mi abuela
si quieres hacer reír a dios cuéntale
tus planes
y les quiero hacer una confesión
el yoga y el budismo no previenen el
miedo
no nos hacen inmortales si nos pueden
ayudar a tratar de atravesar aquello que
nos toca
y recuperarnos si la vida lo permite un
poco más rápido
para la cirugía me preparé de la manera
en la que yo enseño y estoy enseñando
durante una década a la gente hice todo
lo que tenía ganas de hacer con mi lo
que más me gusta de paseos con mi pareja
con mi perro
trate de dormir por supuesto no lo
conseguí
me entregué al caos
ocho horas después y habiendo perdido
dos litros de sangre
salí de la cirugía
y me desperté de la mano de la persona
que amo
y mi primera frase fue el noruego
y el estado te amo
lo que vino después no fue más fácil
toda la recuperación fue lenta tuve que
aprender a caminar de nuevo
y tuve que volver a la vida de una forma
en la que eso no esperaba
toda la luz era mucha
el sonido era demasiado
era una sensación de enorme
vulnerabilidad
como si hubiera perdido toda coraza
los sabores serán nuevos
fue a empezar de nuevo creo que en ese
momento entendí a los bebés cuando
vienen al mundo esa sensación de
invasión
del mundo y el sobresalto frente a todo
tarde meses en poder volver a ver la
televisión
cuántas veces morimos en la vida
yo creo que este tumor me mato que mató
a ese perfeccionista que creía que podía
controlar el resultado de las cosas
la vida
te das sorpresas como dice aquella bella
canción sorpresas te da la vida
yo creo que una de las cosas más
importantes que aprendí es que el amor y
la compasión
son incompletos si no nos contienen a
nosotros mismos
que requiere una enorme fragilidad el
poder reconocerse y que la
vulnerabilidad es el camino para poder
reconocer quiénes somos en esencia
y ustedes quien quieren ser
cuando nos encontramos frente al caos
quienes queremos ser
los que morimos o los que sobrevivimos
al principio cuando salí del hospital ni
siquiera me podía reconocer
al mirarme en una foto o el espejo no
porque mi cara hubiese cambiado sino
porque lo que había cambiado era mi
cabeza mi mano izquierda
yo soy zurdo mi pierna izquierda
empezaron a funcionar distinto tuve que
tirar todos los zapatos que tenía porque
los gastaba diferente y hasta tuve que
cambiarme los anteojos
para la gente yo era el mismo
pero adentro mío yo me sentía una
persona completamente distinta
ese camino me llevo a redescubrir y
enamorarme si podía otra vez de la
persona que soy porque se han oído a
volver a ser la misma persona de antes
igual le agradezco a la persona que fui
porque me trajo hasta aquí literalmente
hasta aquí
yo estoy mejor me recuperación no es
completa por eso mis tarjetas y
empatasen el escenario pero bueno hago
mal camino me siento bien con eso tengo
un pequeño pedacito de mike en la cabeza
que quedó ahí no pudo salir y qué
para mí es el recordatorio junto con la
cicatriz que tengo atrás en mi cabeza de
que lo que yo creía que era imposible es
siempre una posibilidad ahora más
yo creo que desde mis 15 años cuando una
vez casi muero debajo de un autobús
hasta esta intervención creo que debe
haber muerto unas 12 veces en la vida
piense en un instante la cantidad de
veces que cada uno de ustedes ha muerto
y ha vuelto a nacer
y si tuvieran la oportunidad de volver a
nacer que harían con eso
yo creo que cada vez que uno muere es
forzado
a traer nuevas habilidades y a descubrir
un poco más quién es en esencia y a
volverse más resistente
el caos es esa ola que llevar un poco
más lejos
es como una escultura donde un martillo
pega fuerte y después la escultura queda
perfecta
para terminar
todos los días soy testigo de personas
que tienen la posibilidad de renacer
tengo la enorme dicha de poder ser
testigo de ver a la gente
nacer y morir a diario
y quiero terminar con una frase de
marilina walls que dice tantas veces me
mataron tantas veces me morí
ya mi propio entierro fui sola pis
orando
doy gracias a la desgracia y a la mano
con puñal porque me mato tan mal y seguí
cantando
yo creo que el secreto de enfrentar el
caos es honrar quién fuiste
y abrazar al que puede ser
y ustedes quien quieren ser
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]